(audience applauding)
- All right, y'all!
Welcome to the season two premiere
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show!"
(audience cheering)
Give it up for America's dad, Bob Saget!
Thank you so much, Bob.
- I love you, Kelly Clarkson.
- I love you, Bob Saget.
(Kelly laughing)
I love him so much.
He's awesome.
The last time I was on this
stage was over six months ago,
and a lot has changed, for
you, for me, for all of us.
Let's just get this out of the way.
2020 has been a dumpster fire.
Yep, just all the word I
can't say on this show,
just piled together, and it's on fire.
That's really what it feels like.
So, from day one,
I did, though, say that this show
was going to be about connection,
and not even 2020 and
socially distancing ourselves
and all the hurdles are going
to get in the way of that.
We are still going to stay connected,
and I wanted to sing
those classic TV songs
because in hard times
when we're separated,
it's the nostalgic moments
with families and friends
that hold us together.
And, well, you've just
been stuck with them,
if you wanted to or not.
(laughs)
Plus, we've all been
on lockdown, you know,
with nothing else to do but
really binge watch the old shows
'cause we're out of all the new ones,
'cause nobody can tape anything.
It's fine.
(audience laughing)
So give it up for my band, y'all!
They're back!
(audience cheering)
Looking so fly.
We are all back together,
band, crew, all of us!
And we are here in our studio, finally.
We've really been looking forward to this.
I know everyone is in their
own worlds with their jobs,
but a big thank you to my TV
friends who join us today.
Ed Asner from "The Mary Tyler Moore Show!"
(audience cheering)
George Wendt and John
Ratzenberger from "Cheers!"
And David Coulier and Jodie
Sweetin from "Full House!"
Thank you guys so much.
And as you can see,
we have a new kind of
audience as well this season.
These are actually our
brand new house seats
filled with people from
all over the country.
For example, we have Leah dialing in
from her home in Columbus, Ohio.
Wave, Leah, what's up!
Oh, I love the color red.
Wear a great color, yes.
All right, and over there is Eleanor
from Raleigh, North Carolina.
Give it up. Come on, Eleanor!
Give us a wave!
All right, well this is
all thanks to our partners
at The Video Call Center.
We're actually the first to use
their new crowd view
technology, which is super cool.
That means any of you watching from home
can actually use your
cell phone or your laptop
and be in our audience,
which is actually kind of cool.
We're leaning into how we're
navigating the new way.
But just head to kellyclarksonshow.com
to find out how you can be a part
of this fun, fantastic
moment that we're having.
I'm so glad I can still connect
with all of you, though, in my studio
because as you probably know,
2020 has brought a lot of
change also to my personal life.
Definitely didn't see
anything coming that came.
But what I'm dealing with is hard
because it involves
more than just my heart.
It involves a lot of little hearts.
You know, we have four kids,
and divorce is never easy,
and we're both from divorced families,
so, you know, we know the
best thing here is to protect
our children and their little hearts.
So I'm usually very open,
and I usually talk about everything,
but in this case I will talk
a little bit here and there
about how it affects me personally,
but probably won't go too far into it
because, you know, I'm a mama bear,
and my kids come first.
Although I do love you all.
But I am okay.
Everybody keeps asking, "Are
you okay? Are you okay?"
And I am! The answer is yes.
It's one of those things that
it's okay 'cause it matters.
It was something important.
And I know a lot of you
at home, unfortunately,
have probably been through it,
either as a kid or just as yourself
in your own relationships.
So, I feel you,
and it is a bad connection
to have with people,
but I will say this though,
when I got upset when I was a kid,
I had a problem saying how I felt,
and my mom told me to start writing.
And that's actually how
I get my feelings out.
So I probably won't
speak about it too much,
but you definitely will hear it.
Musically, probably.
That's how I became a song writer.
Music's always been my outlet
to help me get through difficult times.
And this year, I've been
listening to a lot of music,
and I've also been writing
a lot of music as well.
So, this week we decided
to dedicate to music.
It's dedicated to musicians,
and it's dedicated to the
way music heals all of us.
And we've got a lineup of
unforgettable performances
you won't want to miss.
And I've been told there
are some surprises,
even if I don't know about them.
Very excited.
Although surprises make
me nervous, but it's fine.